Je sais pas si vous saviez, mais je suis passionné de casse-têtes, enfin j'imagine que vous vous en doutiez. Il y a quelques jours, Doc Seven
m'a dit "mais pourquoi tu fais pas des vidéos de résolution de casse-têtes sur ta chaîne ?" Je me suis dit "OK, pourquoi pas, on peut essayer ça"...
donc j'ai commandé une Pandora Box, que voici,
c'est juste magnifique, et j'ai décidé d'essayer de l'ouvrir sur la chaîne en temps réel.
Mais le hasard a fait qu'aujourd'hui, à la maison, il y a un pote, lui, voilà, c'est bien ça, que vous avez déjà vu...
sur la chaîne, Monsieur Philippe Roche,
imitateur, performeur vocal, humoriste... Mais surtout un pote ! Et mon cher Philippe, nous allons essayer d'ouvrir ça...
ensemble, sachant que c'est une grosse difficulté, la Pandora Box, mais il y a un moyen de l'ouvrir. On a juste besoin de nos doigts...
Je trouve ce programme alléchant !
(PR) Il y en a pour un moment ?
Bah c'est parti !
Premièrement, on va explorer la boîte, un peu comme dans un Escape Game. On ne sait qu'une chose,
c'est qu'on peut l'ouvrir, cette boite. La seule chose qu'on a à savoir, nous, quand on ouvre un casse tête, c'est que il n'y a pas besoin...
d'autre chose que de nos doigts. Voilà. On sait que, en l'état, on doit être capable de l'ouvrir.
(PR) J'ai appuyé dessus et boum !
Ca serait pas mal... [Rires]
Fin de la vidéo ! Merci, au revoir !
Comme je vois plein de trucs comme ça, je pense qu'il faut essayer de voir ce qui peut bouger, déjà. 4 picots...
(PR) En appuyant sur les 4 en même temps ?
(PR) Voilà, pas du tout !
Je les connais, les créateurs de ce genre de truc, c'est à dire que, souvent, ils mettent pleins de trucs en déco pour nous perturber.
(PR) D'accord...
Voilà, pour l'instant, c'est très gênant, il n'y a rien qui bouge. En fait, j'appuie là sur...
sur tous les trucs des 4 côtés, mais y'a...
Alors ça, ça bouge un petit peu, mais je pense que l'ouverture est là.
(PR) On entend un petit "clic".
Ecoutez bien c'est de l'ASMR !
Ecoute, j'ai bien exploré, je te laisse voir qu'est-ce qui peut bouger toi aussi.
(PR) Donc c'est... D'accord.
En vrai j'ai pas la solution, vraiment, on ne finit pas cette vidéo tant qu'on n'a pas ouvert la boîte.
(PR) Ah ! Ca va être une belle journée...
(PR) A aucun moment ça peut partir contre le mur ?
Non !
(PR) Et nous revenir...
Ca c'était pas marqué de la notice !
(PR) On a quand même le droit de le faire avec les mains !
Oui c'est vrai !
(PR) Donc, si...
Non mais toi tu fais partie du clan des hardeurs du casse-tête...
(PR) Je te remercie !
En fait c'est le genre de mec qui, dans un labyrinthe, va prendre juste...
une pelleteuse et va aller tout droit. Il va casser les murs. "Bah quoi, j'suis sorti, il est où le problème mon gars ?".
(PR) Pour l'instant c'est comme toi, mais donc...
(PR) Il y a écrit quelque chose dessus, non ?
C'est la marque des créateurs.
En fait c'est des trucs qui sont vraiment fait en pièce unique, c'est pas industriel, c'est tout fait à la main.
Ca, ça bouge pas ça ?
(PR) C'est impressionnant, on a envie d'appuyer dessus.
(PR) Et... Peut-être en même temps qu'avec le fond ?
J'ai l'impression que ça bouge d'un côté ou de l'autre ?
(PR) Des deux ! Regarde...
(PR) Quand j'appuie...
Lui il bouge, là, le Pandora ?
(PR) Le Pandora bouge.
(PR) Si vraiment tu appuies, le bas et le haut en même temps.
Mais on peut l'enlever en fait !
Pas mal, Roche !
(PR) Je peux pas dire que je suis un génie...
Alors là pour l'instant...
C'est très, très beau. Donc là, c'était retenu par un aimant...
ici, y'a un petit trou comme ça, et je pense, un bout de ferraille...
Est-ce qu'on peut le pousser ça ?
Ca on peut pas le pousser, par contre, moi, j'ai une idée.
C'est à dire que, si ça on a pu le libérer... Je pense que le fait d'appuyer en dessous ne servait à rien, d'ailleurs.
Ca faisait levier...
Et je me dis que, si on a un aimant, et qu'on a ça, ça veut dire que, tu vois...
Alors attends, déjà, on va chercher s'il y a du métal ailleurs. Je pense que tu viens de nous faire gagner une heure, en fait.
(PR) Et puis aussi, je viens de lui faire gagner en temps de vie, parce que sinon je l'aurais vraiment explosé !
Tiens, regarde, prends-le, tu vas sentir...
en fait que ça repousse.
(PR) Ah oui !
Donc voilà ! C'est intéressant...
Alors ça, je pense que c'est pas prévu au programme.
Je pense que je viens de décoller l'élément de l'intérieur.
(PR) Il s'est passé quelque chose, Mesdames, Messieurs, c'est-à-dire que l'aimant a attiré la boule...
métallique qui entraîne la vis.
Par contre, je pense vraiment que j'ai fait de la merde, et qu'il ne fallait pas...
Enfin, je pense que ça, ça s'est décollé de ça, et qu'il fallait pas.
(PR) Et là, du coup, tu vas enlever toutes les vis.
D'accord, là elle ne vient pas.
Elle, elle vient. Donc on a 2 vis qui viennent sur les 3.
OK, donc là, on a toujours le Pandora avec l'aimant, et on a ces 2 vis là, qui m'ont l'air identiques...
Et qui a priori s'ouvrent, comme ça.
(PR) C'est ce que j'allais dire.
[Musique rock]
Et comme là ça tape dans le fond, je pense que si on a pu...
(PR) Donc on est bien d'accord que ce que tu es en train de dire passe en accéléré ?
Non, pas du tout là !
Parce que je pense que c'est... Ah putain c'était ça ! Tu l'as vu s'ouvrir ?
(PR) Oui, je l'ai vu ! J'ai vu...
(PR) J'ai vu le moment où la soirée allait...
Voilà, on va partir sur un apéro plutôt !
Est-ce que ça part sur une ouverture de boîte ?
Ça part sur une ouverture de boite qui est juste tenue par les aimants comme ça.
Putain c'est ouf !
Et là tu mets ce que tu veux là dedans...
On a tué le game !
(PR) En moins de combien ?
Bah je sais pas, écoute, je verrai ça...
déjà, en terme de tournage, ça fait moins de 10 minutes qu'on tourne.
Je crois que c'est vraiment parce que tu as trouvé cette bascule initiale...
(PR) Moi j'ai eu peur aussi ! De passer une soirée... [Rires] Vraiment de merde !
Y'a pas l'air d'avoir 30 000 chemins, en fait, d'ouvertures une fois que t'as ça en fait.  Et bien, écoute, je crois que tu t'ai offert...
une nouvelle passion. Est-ce qu'on verra cette photo, de cette Pandora Box sur ton Instagram ?
(PR) Carrément !
Est-ce que vous irez commenter la photo de Philippe sur son Instagram ? Vous avez son Insta qui apparaît juste ici, en bas de nous.
Vous pouvez le rejoindre, c'est cool.
Clairement, je pensais qu'on en avait pour 30 minutes de tournage. C'était quand même beaucoup moins long.
(PR) Oui, mais tu ne savais pas que j'étais...
Ou j'avais un cerveau extraordinaire apparemment ! J'ai encore lu ton livre...
Ce mec est trop bon !
Je ne sais pas si ça vous plaît comme ça, les casse-têtes sur la chaîne, j'ai envie d'en faire de plus en plus souvent...
vous pouvez me le dire... Peut-être pas dans les commentaires, mais sur mon Instagram. A moi aussi ça me ferait plaisir. Vous l'avez qui s'affiche en bas,
le lien est dans la description, toi même tu sais ! Et là, Philippe, peut-être que tu te dis "Mais où je peux trouver la Pandora Box ?"
(PR) Mais où je peux trouver la Pandora Box ? C'est une bonne question Jean-Jacques !
Ecoute, je vous mets le lien dans la description...
vers le site...
qui fabrique. Je crois qu'il y a un seul site qui fabrique ça. N'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo, à suivre la chaîne...
à très bientôt ! Ciao !